okay for people joining this livestream
um this is one of our series meetings of
incremental language development for of
language in this case getting ready for
things which will be released in the
upcoming version of the language so we
are first looking at geo elevation data
right so this is a continuation of what
we saw last week so yes so there are a
few notes which are tentative the first
one is something simple I wanted to
explain a bit better what gee what geo
it means so I'm offering these two
explanations the parenthesis may I see
them I like the second one I'll take
good potential as as a meaning let's
just talk about gravitational right it
requires some knowledge or the second
one is explicit fine okay so then you
can remove the previous two notes okay
we need to look at this Stephen I think
you want to remove okay so these this
table contains the new options
why isn't center coordinates I don't
understand that wasn't that just
specified and giving in what you asked
geo elevation data to return so the idea
is to have the triple-t arrange the
center oh I see I see I understand what
you're saying because that's what
defines the projection in general you
need a Geo Center to define the
projection is that correct well do
Center is an alternative way of
providing a Geo range given that we are
out into your range it's it's common to
say I gives you the Geo Center and a
zoom level or at the center and a range
of 10 kilometers okay because that's
available in Geographics and your image
etc I thought it was a good idea to fair
enough that's fine
I assume that were explained to people
that we're padding out to the bounding
rectangle
from a from like a circular Center and
radius type model yes that's also what
happens in Geographic so I don't think
this is explicitly mentioned here but
yeah it can be abitt yes so I'm the
whose notes are kind of not for
ourselves it's there we should take the
options bah bah bah and okay
so there is not a center version of the
agreed ranges because we don't have a
plot center say so those are model on
plot range um okay you seem okay
okay a lot of subtle issues here right
now might as well D tentative since I'm
here okay yep okay so I think it's it's
all clear um does it work on those geo
elevation good day to work on Mars as
well yes of course so we have data for
or why does it just say for the moon
because we had it first moon but yes we
have data for for Mars and perhaps for
my curious one I don't remember okay
well so we should
change this note to not just say moon
yes we can add and the last one also
mention in the zoom ranges I can extend
that to say much this one okay well
don't forget other planetary bodies I
mean well I mean there's a limited
number right but but um because for
Jupiter and Saturn there yes yes planet
no the UM well that's Pluto there's you
know Ganymede there's you know all kinds
places series what kinds of places right
we have satellite data for some of them
I'm not sure elevated elevation they
died I can I can check with with Jeff
okay I just think we should generalize
this and you know to planetoid oh you
know whatever it is whatever that right
hand side is fine but I mean geo model
arrow body gives elevation data for read
for a locational region on the moon Mars
or other let me make the change I think
I can do this on reason boy okay so
what about something like that that's
good okay that should also be dealt with
for the other things like Geographics
and so on which probably have the same
as Sue's right yes yes okay minor point
okay let's keep going
yes so last week we decided to add these
four pages so perhaps they are not
completely ready for the situation the
future is Asian but just to have my
first look how extensible yeah so that
there's another example with UTM which
is more interesting so that's used
frequently okay yeah so this allows very
fine control of the maps mm-hmm that's
nice solution
okay so at the North Pole and so on is
that is there a complexity there or not
yes potentially for example if you go
down if you ask for places in which the
resolution may be inconvenient typically
what will happen is that you will end up
requesting tons of styles and then Java
graphics will complain doable if it
corresponds to a reasonable soon it will
be done otherwise okay this is nice very
nice again pure a sighs yes this option
is only used by generation data but it
should be extended to your gravity data
etc exactly I mean that there are other
things I could imagine this being used
on for example gridded population data
and I don't even know I mean that's a
issue for our spatial you should point
out this option to Roger for the spatial
statistics stuff because I don't even
know how we're representing do you know
how we're representing it that we
probably need a function called geo
distribution which gives things like
gridded population density did you are
working on on spatial point data and
similar things and I have discussed this
type of thing with with Roger here
potentially we have a similar situation
as we had with with country data versus
entity country in the sense that
eventually we may have so many sources
of ingredient data that I don't know
whether it's better to start slow with
separated functions or create some
general mechanism I understand I
understand that's a very interesting
question
I mean so imagine so what are some other
examples I mean we we write think of any
meteorological
logical property or astronomical or
whatever yeah I mean the thing is that
the gridded case has to be universal in
the world so to speak so that is saying
I mean it can be you know it has to be a
particular so to speak you can't say the
gridded form of an elephant is such and
such because all elephants are different
so that restricts the set of things that
this can be about it has to be tied to
presumably the earth for example or the
you know or the universe or whatever um
I think it has it has to be
geographically yeah well so I think it
should work through the entity property
framework I think we should basically be
able to say of the world right that
Geographics is I mean it will be
essentially a Geo well you know NGO
distribution right of of them and then
you say what the what
once we say right so then the idea would
be what you would do is to say in
general for something so you might say
geo distribution I mean the idea would
be so geo elevation data so I would
claim the the answer is its geo
distribution of population comma and
then geo region I claim yes certainly we
need those two arguments perhaps in the
opposite order to imitate entity value
because in this case the entity is the
region well what would the default be
and say I don't think there's any entity
unless unless you imagine that there's a
Geo region construct I mean the analog
of an entity will be a Geo region yes we
could go who could give their polygons
or entities representing polygons well
okay so so but that's gonna be a
different thing because geo distribution
well okay this is okay what's our first
example of this we should get one
example like the gridded population data
um I think Allen has the gridded
population data will be a terrific thing
to try you know or you know that the
average temperature data or something
let's just try try putting a few of
these in I mean maybe that's something
for Francisco's team perhaps to try
putting some in yeah and then to try to
understand what it looks like what the
interpolation looks like what in
different projections and so on super
interesting function I would say indeed
um okay
all right are we on to the next thing
yes so okay let me let me try running
subset map for the first time so
okay let's see if I know how subsets map
is supposed to work okay so I say subset
map of F comma actually I can't use F
I've got it I've got to say F of hash
what do I actually have to say I have to
say F over hash want a function that
returns at least from my least like
accumulate does it return the same I'm
gonna use reverse okay so if I say
reverse range of 10 and then I give it 6
7 here for example it'll return 7 6
okay so I want to make a sorting network
for example then let's imagine that I do
let's say I say partition range of 10
comma let's say 2 here and then I could
say subset map can I do this will that
work if I say subset map of that comma
this partition thing no this no at least
this is being interpreted as you have a
matrix 10 by 10 and you want to act on
those okay fine so how do i how do I get
the thing that I'm saying done do I have
to use fold do you want to reverse all
those verbs I want to do this like like
a quantum circuit or like a so this will
be a fold list of this comma and then
this right yes so you can use for
example and that doesn't look very
convincing what is that one to doing
there
oh the fold list or acting always with
reverse sorry on drains 10 so you have
to put the princeton on the second
argument of for list
and then say what yes so exactly okay I
think you can also use the operator form
of subset map which would save one of
the hashes but not both not both
so okay you need to keep the hash too
but but you can't remove the hash one
and remove the ampersand no I can't
remove the ampersand I don't think
that's gonna work because I've got to
still have the ampersand there which
means I can't have hash to be exactly
what kind of mix hashes with so we
separate those forms right right sorry
so in this case you do need today okay
all right okay so what are the questions
about subset map how do we feel about
its name I'm fairly happy with its name
I mean I you know I think it's a kind of
a complicated concept by now I'm used to
it and I like it it's not one of those
cases in which you know you have the
truly right name yeah it's a subset of
parts perhaps we can remove this upset
off
you
and win it parts it's not parts oh yes
in which the elements I don't think we
should say parts here in which the
elements
in the list to make it less obscure here
in the list he 1e2
for those who aren't reading carefully
so to speak whoops oh oh sorry I've
committed this with your uncle okay I
don't think that's not an unclear
description there it's good the thing
I'm missing here is that this function
also works on general position specs so
I'm going to show whether that that's
worth an lining the definition box or
just a note
um I think it's worth a line here um
what do we want to call it pause one or
yes we could say post one posture
actually what we really want to do is
comma dot dot dot here no actually you
know what want to replace we want to
reorder these two definitions right
because if we put this one first then we
can then go to the last one it's just an
F dot dot dot right mess mess mess
you
okay um
um replace the places yeah
elements of exper at positions pause one
pose to dot dot dot okay now this wants
to say F of pause one pause to write yes
or we could say boss spec as you prefer
we can name the whole thing or the
elements okay now we are going to need
to say things about what the hell the
pause I work and so on and for goodness
sake give that example with the fold to
make people know how they can make their
quantum circuits or sorting networks or
whatever yes there are examples for
along with fault yeah like this with
nest
I used nest I think you want
give the sorting Network example I think
you can give a bubble sort or something
um I'm not completely sure what which
one bubble sort is for this but I think
you can give that I mean like actually
what you really want is to give
something to yeah look look here's what
we want so what we want is
no it's actually it's it's actually
simply a sort it's a pass pairwise sort
right yes but we would have to choose
carefully they're the least of burrs
no you just keep going for a long a long
long long time
right so if we just do the let's do this
ah here this is a random integer 110
like 40 comma 2 okay then I claim wow
it's really an efficient I mean there
then I get I guess after wow that's
really an efficient okay let's let's try
them well here let's just just for fun
um well yeah we can also do this I just
want to see it see it doing its thing um
that's the right thing transpose of that
and then let's line plot am i right am I
wrong
yeah it's it's doing something not sure
if this
right but but anyway they I'm not sure
if this is quite right I'm gonna put
this in just as a reminder for you okay
um okay I think this is the winner um
any problems here the two corner cases
which is how would you write before you
look at it how would you write the actor
know parts and or act on all parts okay
why do you want that well they are
corner cases that will appear in some
situations so they need to have some
syntax so so what's the third argument
that returns the list itself an F of the
full list um we have a question on our
live stream hold on a second about
whether something should be legal syntax
let me just do it it's being asked here
so should this be legal syntax as
opposed to so this is making a nested
list there right
this person is suggesting that the fold
be an automatic folding process well the
way this implant this is implemented
right now is following extract extras
would try to do everything at the same
time willis extract all those parts at
the same time and then act on all of
them at the same time right I mean the
truth is the useful case of this is
often going to involve folding but it's
a little bit obscure because what's
gonna end up happening is you're gonna
have to say list slash
and then the list of pairs that you do
the operation on and that will end up
being the thing that you subset map I
think for itself should be used for this
operation to avoid over complicating
this index fair enough okay Sandra our
live stream says you have to distinguish
a list from folding yeah yeah yes yes no
he's just making the point that it's but
the syntax is messy if you try and auto
fold okay so what are you asking you're
asking if one of the elements here was
supposed to apply to everything yes so
I'm thinking about corner cases for the
third document or for example in that
case I have an example for the lamb
which is others recently I think it's
not going to work in what you have but
for example look at this matrix have the
elastic basic example okay and I'm
seeing this plus coloured matrix I'll
sculpt Hawkeye matrix yes this these two
example so here you see in the first one
you see their standard position spec a
list of positions yes a specification of
the Dayani and the other one is saying
act on the second column
as to that being in a double list
exactly we could write 1 - 2 - 3 - I
don't think that syntax as you have it
is right I mean in other words I think
that syntax as you have it would default
to something a little bit crazy that
would involve I mean I understand that
there's no meaningful way in which that
could be the equivalent of like 2 3 or
something meaning just do it in one
place I don't understand well because
the the simplest case this case here
right yeah um how do you distinguish
this case which is very different case
because that case is effectively a list
of pairs right it's effectively
understood first right and I think it's
slightly obscure that that one level
list can be both a specific you know
thing like this and yes it can be also
at least at least two lists for you
could produce the same output
recall that the objective here is to
have the third argument be in a position
spec exactly like extract with the
exception that the list of numbers
represents a list of positions rather
than a deep sea no I understand that
right so what's your point that all
comma 2 is accepted by extract so I
think people will expect here
let's subset mark also accept all right
ok all right I don't regret to this what
was the next corner case yes I think in
their properties I have the two corner
cases which is empty list and yeah this
the last two examples yes I
that one the first one is clearer the
second one is new because that's not
accepted by extract extract as an
acceptor so what that's doing is it's
taking the whole list applying the
operation that's the equivalent of just
construct accumulate list exactly that's
what I would expect it to do but the
point understand is that this is a new
notation motivated by this exception we
are introducing of a list of numbers the
previous one is not an exception is the
right thing okay why is it an exception
again I mean what else could this mean
try extract of at least coma all it's
gonna return the list isn't it no it
doesn't work for some reason it doesn't
work well I don't think I think that's
wrong I think it should just work which
means then it would be consistent if
this works in extract then I would I
think it's I think it's just a bug that
doesn't work and extract okay okay
numerator denominator it's a simple
function
did we on few tries subset map by the
way I are we gonna
at my experimental I think we should for
right now just in case there's a design
problem with it
like that that need to be in that boy
mutator
impossible or the name for this without
city of that but because we are
introducing the brand strand functions
some point yeah it might be confusing to
yes that's true um basement yeah by the
way the other alternate names that we
thought up we should look at those as
possible keywords here extract works
with all if you put all in the list
which is ok well so it probably should
work not unless that make it consistent
I think ok numerator/denominator
pics are terms which do not have ok oh
it's nice that the works on rational
numbers right that's useful ok
I mean I don't think I need to see this
really yeah great all good ordering by
guide page yes we had a discussion and
we didn't know where to put it so we
have three suggestions here ok ok
which one what level of obscurity are
these various suggestions at so to speak
the suggestions are motivated by the
presence of either ordering or salt pie
so I think these were given in the order
of preference
where would you put it on this page
together with these their shorts or by
ordering or limbo all right to be needed
on other pages as well I know it's not
very fundamental function we need to
have it in one I'm happy with having it
here okay let's just have it there take
largest yes so here and then he added
the new notation for roots property
rules which is that the second
you
um why are we putting the list of
properties not after all countries say I
mean we're following exactly what
nearest government we're trying to be
consistent with that
you
okay I mean oh wait a minute this wants
to say take largest
Astrea property
I'm sorry I'm just having a hard time
parsing what you wrote here
do you mean well the largest elements
right why don't we say the largest
elements themselves and the indices of
the largest elements an association
giving elements and indices is that
correct yes
if
yet I'm surprised by that maybe I've
just got the wrong version here I add
for the wrong version magnificent
I see this isn't right so son when a
live stream is asking us take largest
getting updated to accept a negative
second argument so that it switches to
take smallest I believe we discussed
this before and I believe this is not as
trivial as one thinks right because of
ties and so on I don't think that works
to put the negative I I I don't remember
why but I believe it doesn't work okay
I'm not I'm not happy with this element
singular um okay so maybe we should say
elements and indices
should say elements and indices I don't
agree I think I think it's important to
keep the same notation we have in
nearest alright and this is a okay okay
all right
give give the actual element perhaps
element in the list of of largest
elements or something that I I do
realize that we need a singular in the
explanation
yeah well so take largest possible props
include give each element itself here
index of it for each element is it give
or gives give an association with with
index and element I think it should be
the other way around unless there's only
a good reason to not to have it this way
round it's perhaps subject politically
okay
yeah Sandler is suggesting the transpose
of that of that Association Lisp I don't
think that's right I think this is the
right way around to do it
each individual thing works this way
exactly okay I'm happy with that
okay last and not least probably our
most controversial discussion of the day
um I thought I'd say
little bit more than this but this this
the idea of this was yes you had a
string I think yeah the possibility of
slash you know whatever it is slash user
you know use a local and then quotes you
know bin slash bin foo okay turning into
and maybe this is crazy
file of using local Ben foo I said you
were talking about structures access or
sort of information from the file I
think maybe I've talked about two
different things on two different
occasions which is not a good sign I
would have expected that if we have an
object and then we have strings separate
argument that's a property extraction
well what would the let's see do we have
other people here who are relevant to
this discussion or not because I think
this discussion involved needs other
people we need to Constantine anything
for these right but that's my proposal
um and Sushma I'm going to write that
back in there I mean I think that was my
current proposal was to use that as a
way to you know maybe we just should
have a function that does that
particular thing on a file name because
it seems like that's the thing people
always want I think Michael said that we
have file I'm not sure the freedom you
have inside file but if inside file you
have something like a file name join
with the various parts separated then
perhaps a method string could extract
the full thing already joint
okay all right well so that's a detailed
thing okay so we need a separate
discussion about this right well there's
some things that I just sent through to
ILD in the last few days that I don't
know if they made it onto this list No
okay well anyway good we finished right
on time
so let's just declare victory here um
okay
thank you and thanks to everybody on the
livestream and I'm sure we will be doing
more meetings let's take a look at what
tomorrow brings oh we've got yet more
database integration and we've got a
graphs and networks discussion for
tomorrow at least that's the current
plan and for Friday we have some
geometric computing so lots of cool
stuff well we've got one which I doubt
mm you might do is a design of a tension
layer for neural nets that may be too
too grim to livestream I'm not sure um
all right great thanks talk to you all
soon